on the outskirts of the ukrainian
capital the cleanup has barely begun
in neighborhoods once controlled by
russian forces residents are returning
to pick up the pieces but lurking in the
rubble a lingering danger
after four months of war ukraine is
littered with land mines bombs and other
explosives remnants of russian rockets
along with booby traps deliberately set
this area was was all russian positions
this british army veteran is part of a
team of foreign volunteers working
alongside ukrainian police to safely
remove and destroy unexploded ordnance
and they've got their work cut out and
this is just a small fraction of what
they've recovered so far quite a wide
range of explosive devices brought here
to this secret warehouse from anti-tank
mines to mortar shells to missiles
85 000 pieces recovered the team has
found explosives hidden in homes
playgrounds cemeteries even underwater
some like these cluster submunitions are
so sensitive even a change in
temperature can trigger an explosion a
lot of civilians they'll if they find
artillery shells or something in the
house they'll move them put them inside
the road
they do that with submunition and
they're detonating because they're just
so volatile dozens of ukrainian
civilians have already been killed most
are agricultural workers like vadim
i drove past here a couple of days ago
and i was fine he says but the second
time through his truck hit an anti-tank
mine incredibly he escaped with minor
injuries this area was marked as
dangerous but farmers are now forced to
risk their lives or their livelihoods
the agricultural companies that rent
lease the land here are under huge
pressure to generate food
and that's that's basically driving them
so people are taking risks the
non-profit group the halo trust has been
demining ukraine since 2014 after
russian-backed separatists first
attacked the east the team had just
finished clearing the city of mariupol
when russia invaded it's definitely
challenging especially when the conflict
is still ongoing the halo trust is one
of few organizations willing to operate
in an active war zone and they recently
received two million dollars from the
canadian government canada was the first
country the first new donor to respond
to our call it will be a challenge and
will continue to be a challenge for many
many years for ukraine officials
estimate that 300 000 square kilometers
will need to be cleared an area the size
of newfoundland and labrador that grows
larger as the war drags on
experts predict it will take not years
but decades before these neighborhoods
are finally safe
jeff semple global news